the jury has reached an official verdict
for the case of Jonathan Maes and Grace
Jabari and has found Jonathan Maes
guilty of two out of the four charges
pressed against him and of course now
the big questions are one is he going to
do any jail time for this and two is
Marvel Studios going to drop him as
their main big bad villain of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Multiverse Saga there
is still a little bit of hope that
Marvel Studios might keep him as
Jonathan major was found guilty of two
cases which were the minor cases that
were charged against him we'll go over
everything that has just happened today
only a few minutes ago in this video
most people are probably aware but
Jonathan majers was accused of harassing
and assaulting his now ex-girlfriend
then girlfriend at the time Grace Yari
in a private car in March he was charged
with third degree assault second degree
aggravated harassment second degree
harassment and an additional third
degree assault charge with intent to
cause physical harm now like I said he
was only convicted of two of these two
of these other ones were dropped so he
was found not guilty of second degree
aggravated harassment and found not
guilty of third degree assault with
intent to cause physical harm he was
found guilty on two of the charges which
were third degree assault recklessly
causing physical injury and second
degree harassment which is a
non-criminal charge fortunately for him
these were the lesser of the charges
that he could have been charged with
right now it is said that he still could
face up to one year in jail however they
have not decided his sentencing yet they
have set the sentencing date for
February 6th so we won't know if he's
going to be going to prison until about
a month and a half from now this verdict
was reached by a six-person jury after
roughly over 4 hours of deliberation
which was spread across 3 days Thursday
Friday and then picked up again today
Monday Jonathan major showed up to court
today wearing a gray suit and a black
dress shirt and taii and he sat with his
attorneys his family members and with
his girlfriend Megan good so here's what
to know about these charges third degree
assault is the lowest assault that you
can be charged with there's first degree
second degree and third degree first
degree assault is intentionally
inflicting fear of serious bodily harm
or intentional infliction of fear of
injury caused by a deadly weapon second
degree assault is knowingly inflicting
fear of serious bodily injury or
knowingly inflicting a fear of injuries
with a deadly weapon third degree
assault which is what he was charged
with is The Reckless infliction of fear
of serious bodily injury or recklessly
causing a fear of injury through the use
of a deadly weapon this is what he was
charged with basically Reckless
infliction of fear of serious bodily
injury which they are claiming is what
Jonathan major did in the car that in
the car the altercation that went down
where Grace Jabari grabbed Jonathan
Major's phone and he attempted to get it
back to her in that moment he recklessly
inflicted fear into her that she was
going to receive bodily injury that he
was going to hurt her so fortunately for
Jonathan major this is the lowest degree
of assault that you can be charged with
luckily for him the jury decided that it
wasn't intentional he did not seek out
to make her fear that she was going to
receive bodily harm or injuries from him
but he did put that fear in her with his
actions and these definitions of what
the degrees of assault are are coming
from legal match.com now he was also
charged with second deegree harassment
which means a pattern of intentional
substantial and unreasonable intrusion
into the private life of a targeted
person that serves no legitimate purpose
and causes the person and will cause a
reasonable person in his position to
suffer mental or emotional distress
harassment in the second degree may
include but is not limited to verbal
written or electronic contact that is
initiated maintained or repeated and
laww insider.com states that a person
commits harassment in the second degree
when the person commits harassment
involving a threat to commit bodily
injury or commits harassment and has
previously been convicted of harassment
two times under this section or any
similar statute during the preceding 10
years and it is a misdemeanor so
basically it was harassment because of
the threat to commit bodily injury to
Grace Jabari and some websites are
reporting that this is coming from the
video of Jonathan major picking gra
Jabari up and trying to put her back
into the Town Car forcefully this is
coming from law insider.com so these are
the charges that Jonathan major was
found guilty of now like I mentioned
this leaves us with two major questions
one is Jonathan major going to face jail
time and two what is Marvel Studios
going to do with him now I think that
there's a lot that's going to go into
influence Marvel's decision and Disney's
decision but it's not looking good
obviously for Jonathan major the good
news about what he was charged with is
that none of them were based on
intentionally causing bodily harm or
fear to Grace Jabari they basically
state that he didn't seek out to hurt
her or scare her or intentionally make
her believe that she was going to
receive bodily harm from him but just
during his actions which they deemed as
Reckless he did put that fear in her so
you could state that it was just an
altercation he was trying to get his
phone back but the way he did it and the
events that proceeded after with him
lifting her up and trying to put her
back into the car before he ran away
that was not intentional he wasn't
trying to hurt her it just happened
during this altercation he didn't seek
out to do this he's not a bad person
that is one way that Marvel Studios
could look at it that is the way a lot
of the public seems to be looking at it
right now from what I've seen based off
of Instagram and Twitter Etc so Marvel
Studios could look at it like that also
The public's opinion I think will
definitely play a role into what Marvel
and Disney triy to do I will say right
now the headlines against Jonathan
majors are not good of course all of the
Articles right now are Jonathan majes
was found guilty of harassment and
assault obviously not a very good look
for him and it Paints the picture that
he went out to physically harm Grace
Jabari and that is what he did which is
not accurate to what he has been charged
with however he was still found guilty
of two of these charges and he could
still face jail time he still could go
to prison that's also going to be a
pretty big factor if Jonathan Maes goes
to prison I think Marvel Studios doesn't
have a choice but to let him go I think
that might be a line for Disney Marvel
Studios if he goes to prison they have
to let him go as king the Conqueror they
can recast him or like we've been
hearing recently they can simply move
away from the character maybe introduce
Dr Doom although I really think that
recasting would be the best decision if
he goes to prison right now they could
actually still get away with keeping him
as king the Conqueror they would have to
make him maybe issue an apology about
the situation stating that no he did not
mean to hurt her but given how the
situation played out he made a couple of
wrong choices that at the moment he
didn't think think were that bad but
ultimately were and he never meant to do
any of it and that he's sorry but again
public opinion will really matter on
this I'm not sure if this is enough to
cancel him if he was convicted of all of
the charges against him I would say yeah
it's definitely enough to cancel him if
he intentionally went out to hurt this
woman then I would definitely say yeah
fire him he's an abuser and there are
going to be people who are already
stating that right now and of course on
both sides there are always going to be
people that do not agree with the
verdict some are going to say I don't
agree with this he's completely innocent
he shouldn't have gotten charged with
anything and some will say he should
have been charged with everything like I
said public opinion probably is going to
matter Marvel and Disney will probably
take that into consideration that
combined with any jail time he might
serve are probably going to determine
his fate as Kane the Conqueror in the
MCU but let us know what you think about
this in the comments down below do you
think he was innocent do you think he
was guilty or do you think this was a
just sentencing let us know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe stay up to date on the MCU and
all things Marvel and if you subscribe
and leave a comment down below you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win a PS5 and Xbox
series X some Marvel Legends items and
some DC items winner picks one item and
we pick one winner at the end of each
month you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof